here are a few common types of market
segmentation practices behavioral
psychographic demographic Geographic
occasional and cultural segmentation
let's start by talking about behavioral
and psychographic segmentation
behavioral segmentation considers a few
things such as the knowledge of your
product their attitude towards your
product how or how often they use your
product or how they respond to your
product their loyalty to your product
and you can also think about creating a
segment based on what your customer will
benefit from your product now behavioral
segmentation is a great place to start
when you think about segmenting your
market let's take an energy bar for
example what's important to you do you
look at the price do you look at the
calories do you want something that has
less calories or more calories do you
look at the protein or maybe you don't
care and you're just hungry
our messaging for each of these segments
so the people who are just hungry that
people who want more protein or less
calories or the people who care about
the price the message is going to be
different and it's going to be affected
by the different benefits that these
customers seek we also need to think
about the places online or offline where
our customers may find each of these
segments so say it's offline we may
consider to put a poster in a gym
marketing our energy bar and online we
might want to add an ad to a page that
sells workout clothes now let's talk
about psychographic segmentation this
segmentation is achieved by studying
activities interests in the opinions of
your customers you're thinking about the
lifestyle of your customer how do they
spend their downtime what are they
influenced by what image are they trying
to project what are the needs and wants
of people in this common lifestyle group
for example usually people who buy a
luxury car can not only afford it thus
defining their economic status but it
also shows a preference to spend money
on more luxury lifestyle products so we
can extrapolate that they may travel to
high-class destinations where specific
brands are visits
establishments so say we're trying to
sell a luxury car if we want to market
to people who can afford it we're going
to consider doing that in other high-end
places like such as a luxury magazine
found in the first-class section of an
airline or sponsoring the valet outside
of an expensive restaurant